ich kämpfe für meine zukunft ich spreche
für alle zukünftigen generationen ich
spreche für die zahllosen tiere die auf
der welt sterben weil sie keinen
lebensräume haben klingt vertraut klingt
doch wie genau guttenberg unsere
ökosysteme kollabieren
wir stehen am beginn eines
massensterbens seit 30 jahren ist die
wissenschaft eindeutig wie könnt ihr es
wagen weiter weg zu sehen
greta klingt wie silvan suzuki doch ist
deren rede schon fast 30 jahre her
damals 1992 war sie ein teenager hielt
in rio eine rede vor den un und brachte
die weltöffentlichkeit für ein paar
minuten zum schweigen
ihr anliegen das klima ihre waffe die
worte einer zwölfjährigen ich träume
davon werden wilder tiere zu sehen den
dschungel und den regenwald voller vögel
und schmetterlinge aber werden meine
kinder sie auch noch sehen kann
27 jahre später erreichen wir sie zwei
flugstunden nordwestlich von vancouver
kanada sie ist immer noch aktivistin im
einsatz für die umwelt kretas rede hat
sie gesehen klar ist als erwachsene und
mutter war ich sehr bewegt von gretas
rede der wut in ihrer stimme ich
erinnere mich an das gefühl als ich kind
war und nicht verstanden habe warum
erwachsene das artensterben zu lassen
was sich seit 1992 verändert hat eine
ganze menge
der co2 ausstoß weltweit ist deutlich
gestiegen der meeresspiegel auch von
etwa acht millionen tier und
pflanzenarten weltweit sind bis zu einer
million aktuell vom aussterben bedroht
warum gerät höhenberg heute mehr
menschen erreicht als selber an suzuki
vor 30 jahren
heute ist es einfach anders wir spüren
die folgen des klimawandels es gibt
hurricanes überschwemmung im wald
ende und dann haben wir die möglichkeit
unseren protest über die sozialen
netzwerke zu organisieren
das gab es damals nicht
wie die welt in 27 jahren aussieht das
weiß suzuki natürlich nicht sie hofft
nur dass die politik anders als vor 30
jahren
dieses mal auch wirklich handelt